hello today we are going to talk about
stepwise linear discriminant analysis
that is used to find a subset of the
provided features that optimally
separates the classes inherit in the
data
in this procedure a discriminant model
is built iteratively starting with an
empty set of features
lda classification is evaluated on each
feature and the feature resulting in the
highest accuracies added to the optimal
feature set
more and more features are iteratively
added to the set in order of maximum
improvement of accuracy until no
significant improvement is provided by
further features
lda classification can be performed
using a subset of optimal features
without including strongly co-related or
redundant or noisy features which is
known as a forward selection procedure
feature selection is different from
dimensionality reduction although both
methods seek to reduce the number of
attributes in the data set a
dimensionality reduction method does so
by creating new combinations of
attributes feature selection methods
include and exclude attributes present
in the data without changing them
so now to see how this process works
let's run
sw swlda on the tbi info platform
let's use the same input file as for the
other classification pipelines that
include train and test data
you can download the data from lesson
number 15 under transcriptomics on the
portal
you will notice that we have an
additional parameter called niview
it is a user defined parameter for the
stop criterion of feature inclusion
for our expression data which in which
contains expression levels for almost
7000 genes we set this value to 0.005
however for smaller sets higher values
are generally used that is 0.1 or in
some cases lower parameters may be
required when you run this pipeline you
need to play around with the navy
parameter to get it to work correctly
try using point one point zero one point
zero zero one or maybe point zero zero
zero one and compare your outputs
now check the results of the pipeline
we find that it's selected just 17 genes
which are found in discriminant
function.txt output file and if you look
at the confusion matrix we will see the
swa lda achieved 100 accuracy in
predicting the class of test data
to learn more about swlda and how this
algorithm works
and how do you interpret the results
obtained you may visit lesson number 15
under transcriptomics on the honest
logic learn portal